jean paul gaultier car oui ça se
prononce ainsi je répète jean paul colti
à briser les codes de la mode masculine
autodidacte il a les mêmes convictions
depuis ses débuts casser les genres et
montrer la masculinité autrement que
dans un costume trois pièces
pourquoi je lis monsieur il y avait bien
jolie madame alors pourquoi pas joli
monsieur je lis monsieur ça veut dire
tout simplement que les hommes aussi
peuvent séduire qu'ils ont droit de
séduire tous les il y avait jusqu'à
présent l'image de john wayne avec
l'homme sécurisant bon ok très bien
peut-être mais il ya aussi peut y avoir
une image d'un homme qui séduit les
femmes on sait général tous ceux qui ont
déballé en 1983 son défilé s'appelle toy
boy
autrement dit l'homme objet en 1985 le
styliste chamboule les codes en faisant
porter des jupes longues aux hommes ont
sitôt que j'ai fait ça il ya eu une
certaine image enfin montrant une
ambiguïté mais en vérité il n'y a
absolument pas d'ambiguïté à cela au
comptant je connais des tas de garçons
qui sont même des coureurs de jupons mes
deux filles je veux dire par là et qui
porte la jupe
alors qu'il est accusé d'être un
provocateur gauthier revendique être à
l'écouté d'une société qui change ou les
stéréotypes hommes femmes plus lieu
d'être
il se trouve que les gens peut-être sont
plus habitués à une espèce de
provocation de recherche pour la femme
il est tout à passer ça alors que pour
l'homme disons c'est +9 la mode pour
homme à faire et il n'y avait pas de
mode pour homme en continuant sur cette
lancée en 2002 le couturier fait défiler
ses mannequins hommes talons aiguilles
ni les chocs aujourd'hui mais qui dit
que demain elle ne sera pas rentré dans
les moeurs et un an plus tard il sort
une ligne de maquillage pour mme
évidemment la femme se maquille ballom
aussi je rêve d'avoir des sourcils bruns
sombre et tout est brillant j'ai pas du
tout ça j'ai les poils blonds et
transparent du coup le maquillage et ben
ça peut aider a souligné ce regard
justement et en l'appuyant en le
contraire de les piles et moi c'est le
contraire
si donc un maquillage virilisant ses
maquillages pour hommes maquillage jupe
talons il a osé faire porter les
attributs de la femme à l'homme
tout comme yves saint laurent avait fait
porter le smoking à la femme un vêtement
devenu banal aujourd'hui dans la
garde-robe féminine
femelles et pour les animaux
[Musique]